y
[Música]
bienvenidos a este avance informativo en
france 24 gracias por estar con nosotros
mi nombre es juan pupiales en este
momento les ofrecemos una programación
reducida en medio de la contingencia
sanitaria a causa de la pandemia que se
vive en colombia y particularmente en
bogotá desde donde transmitimos
comenzamos en israel el parlamento
nombró como presidente a isaac herzog un
veterano político que llegó a liderar al
partido laborista y fue derrotado en
2013 por benjamín netanyahu cuando
aspiraba a ser primer ministro este
miércoles se impuso en una votación por
87 votos a favor y 26 en contra el
próximo mes será el sucesor de reuvén
rivlin que termina su periodo de siete
años en el cargo el shock asumirá un
papel protocolario sobre todo pero justo
el mismo día en que termine el plazo
para que los opositores al premier
benjamin netanyahu formen una nueva
coalición de gobierno de lo contrario se
convocarían unas nuevas elecciones
ocho de los diez países con las mayores
tasas de mortalidad hoy en día se
encuentran en sudamérica es la alarma
que lanzó la organización mundial de la
salud que expresó su preocupación por lo
que ocurre en esta región además cuatro
de las diez naciones con las cifras más
altas de contagios son en sudamérica
brasil argentina chile y colombia de
hecho este último territorio registró el
martes un nuevo récord de casos con 25
mil 966 positivos desde la o&m se
explican que esto podría deberse a la
falta de acceso al personal médico y la
presión que la pandemia ha ejercido
sobre los sistemas sanitarios en varios
países
anthony blinken el secretario de estado
de eeuu comenzó el martes su primera
visita a latinoamérica desde el comienzo
de la administración de joe biden
blinken está en costa rica ayer se
reunió con el presidente carlos alvarado
y también sostuvo un encuentro con los
cancilleres de centroamérica méxico y
república dominicana nin quien hizo un
llamado a estas naciones para reforzar
su lucha contra la inmigración irregular
el secretario el presidente de eeuu
jobvite en suspendió los arrendamientos
de petróleo y gas en el refugio nacional
de vida salvaje del ártico situado en
alaska y esto cierra las puertas a las
perforaciones petrolíferas en un área 17
como 9 millones de hectáreas y que es el
hogar de osos polares entre otro tipo de
fauna esta medida revoca una normativa
aprobada por la administración de donald
trump que buscaba expandir el desarrollo
de combustibles posibles en la unión
americana
el gobernador de alaska el republicano
lamentó la decisión argumentando un
golpe a la economía de la región
y seguimos en eeuu yo bailé se convirtió
en el primer presidente en visitar el
lugar de la masacre de tulsa en oklahoma
a propósito de los 100 años de uno de
los peores capítulos de la historia de
violencia racial del país en 1921 una
turba racista atacó los hogares de un
barrio afroamericano dejando al menos
300 personas fallecidas el mandatario
reafirmó su compromiso de acabar con el
racismo sistémico en el país y anunció
medidas destinadas a cerrar la brecha
económica que afecta mayoritariamente a
los afroamericanos sobre todo en materia
de vivienda
[Aplausos]
por doloroso que sea sólo recordando se
sanan las heridas solo tenemos que
elegir recordar hacemos memoria a lo
ocurrido aquí en tulsa para que pueda
ser borrado conocemos este lugar sagrado
simplemente no podemos enterrar el dolor
y el trauma para siempre y en cierto
punto debe haber una reparación un punto
de inflexión como el que estamos
enfrentando ahora mismo
como nación 24